the time on the bottom is critical if
that's our bread and butter so to speak
so we use every second
the Alvin is the United States deepest
diving man submersible we're capable of
going to 4,500 meters at one time in the
past the lunches were but varied there
was a particular lunch that caused some
gastronomical distress and they had to
abort the dive
we do all these amazing things but the
people that make the food on board the
ship they're heroes they really are they
put a lot of thought into it and they
keep people really happy important
morning begins with the making of the
Elven lunch we keep peanut butter and
honey mixed up this is the favorite
combination and the one that pleases
everybody everybody's got a favorite jam
but it it's not the same as the next guy
you're not going down there to dine in
splendor you need fuel food this is what
we will provide something real
nutritious we will provide the wheat
bread it's the best most wholesome
choice after which it goes in lunch we
seal it up place it in the bag turn this
up cold water thermos of hot coffee I
[Music]
love peanut butter
Digga see how the honey gets off Chris
away but clearly we have to ask whether
people are allergic to peanut butter it
would be impossible for humans to visit
the deep ocean without a machine like
Alvin we don't stop for lunch typically
what will happen is you get a breather
from the work you reach back and grab
your lunch you've grabbed a sandwich and
you're looking out the window flying
this up take a bite - sandwiches - it
I've had close to 350 dives in the
submarine all over the world's oceans
and various different places and depths
and seeing almost indescribable amazing
places
[Music]
I would wager that anybody who's eaten a
peanut butter honey sandwich and Alvan
every time they eat one thinks about
their dive
[Music]